welcome back to the Rich Eisen show here
in Miami go we have had a fun show so
far dak Prescott Steve Harvey the actors
miles teller in Glen Powell from Top Gun
maverick Derrick Henry just left and I
turn to my right and find my compadre
from NFL gameday morning who's been with
NFL Network since 2006 my lord one of
the great coaches from the San Francisco
49ers back in the day Detroit lines and
my great friend Steve Mariucci what's up
mooch oh yeah everybody rich poem okay I
can't wait to see that movie Top Gun
maverick that's that looks awesome do
you love the original Top Gun I love it
yeah what's your favorite movie Steve my
Ricci's favorite movie Bryan song really
remember the Titans
I'm not talking about football come on
Steve expand your horizons huh what are
you go your favorite movie of all time
your notebook nope stop are you serious
like gladiator like come on by the way
do you know who said his favorite movie
of all time was notebook this is not a
joke this is not know Terrell Owens
well his grandmother had Alzheimer's I
know yeah did you mind that did you and
teal watch that we'll be together once
oh did you school together one night and
just know I didn't rich I would all
right so why are you limping you know
you said you're banged up now now let's
get to it why are you banging Steve so
every school every Super Bowl the NFL
Network asks Michael Irvin and I to do
some crazy stuff right yeah you want ice
fishing a minute we like fishing in
Minnesota you know I had a grumpy old
man a fur coat and tennis shoes so we
went ice fishing last year in Atlanta
when wrapping we did have we did a rap
video yeah that embarrassed the family
we did what did you do no we did Miami
Vice what do you think what do we do
okay I'm Eve ice okay so yesterday well
yet we had the I had the white linen
suit up okay
I was Sonny Crocket just in case yet he
was Tubbs okay
we had to get the jheri-curl wig on and
off but no we filmed it all day long
okay [ __ ] oh there we go there's a
photograph of it right there that's
phenomenal
that's that
the Ferrari that Don Johnson and his
guys use that's a 1986 oh sure and that
is you that's us look at that an herb
fantastic okay so college you get here's
what happened you know filming some of
these things and rich I'm 64 years old
okay just in case you wondered so one of
the scenes was Michael line that were
talking and all of a sudden some guy
stole our car so I had a run after him
well I ran after the guy that stole our
Ferrari and I blew my calf out okay you
try to run in the beach sand all right
without stretching and then another
another scene was the bad guy stole some
stuff and I'm running down the beach and
I had a tackle this guy yeah and it was
the real it was the real stuntman for
Don Johnson from from Miami Vice back in
the day yeah I got him rich I got him
brought him down my handspring blue just
like yours did at the combine okay so
now I can't even walk they want to run
it again and I was a nice all night last
night are you serious yeah but wait let
comes out it's gonna be good what do you
mean what's what's it that comes out the
feet or the feet that filter you're
gonna see it on Sunday look at that we
had our police no calf no hammy blown so
so an ribs I hurt my ribs I everything
so it's a it's Thursday Steve what is
your injury designation for game day
morning pregame show about seven and a
half hours on Sunday what are you what
are you in questionable right now last
night I would have been doubtful but I
thought ice ice works wonders rich
father that's a great great saying nice
works wonders all right in the drinks
I'm talking about in a bag on your hammy
did you tell me you heard Andy Reid's
quote of this century today Oh what did
I say he was asked about his nine
grandkids okay
quote they keep you young and at the
same time they make you feel old it's
kind of like sweet and sour pork
that's what we had when I went near
beautiful we had support pulled pork is
a sweet quote unquote that's like that's
great kids are like sweet and sour pork
does he always think of food is it less
or not hey any reason man you know what
I think this young kid mahomes has just
rejuvenated it don't you think you know
people are wondering if he's gonna go on
the Hall of Fame and all that stuff and
and and I interviewed him last week and
I asked him about his legacy he really
he doesn't like talking about that
there's not nobody has all right but he
doesn't have retirement in mind because
I asked them all nine grandkids in a
paddleboards over in Dana Point right
and you know what he goes I did it I get
enough of that in one month in the
summer right and it's football are you
the same age are you both 64 or easier
look he's gonna be 62 okay he's a kid as
you pointed out you mentioned this when
we had you on the show a couple weeks
ago I mean let's just say he wants to
coach eight more years right
then you have to say if mahomes is
healthy on average that that might be
anywhere between 80 to 90 more with 300
I mean like that's this kid anywhere
yeah I mean yeah they're gonna be joined
at the hip like you know Chuck Noll
Bradshaw Walsh Montana you know the
coach quarterback combination he's only
24 years old well you got to win
championships for that to happen yeah
does that happen on Sunday Steve you
want me to give you my game picked
Stadium Rich Eisen hurt Oh Curt yes did
Curt him and Hawk
hurt hemmed and hawed all I'm not Curt
I'm not hurting hard but then did land
on a team if you want me to tell you
before your pick I don't care what
Curtis but I figured so I can't decide
yet I got a look at um I got to look at
it a little closer this just in Steve
Mariucci on the fence is literally dog
bites man's story I mean that's
basically it really mixed emotions about
this okay you know because because
having moon San Francisco I know those
coaches and a lot of doors and right
front everybody and I have a certain
appreciation and respect for that
organization and then of course Andy
Reed is one of my best buds and and it's
some of his coaches too and
and I just I'm torn alright so then like
your hamstring let's approach it this
way what the poll question brought to
you by Callaway's maverick thinking has
been completely changing the way
distance is designed forever Callaway
used advanced artificial intelligence
and new materials to unlock the next
level of speed and forgiveness in the
new maverick driver get new distance
today at Callaway golf comm as Steve the
poll question let's see if we can glean
something through the answer here's
alright mood to do you think is gonna be
Super Bowl MVP and the OSI so if I say
Patrick Mahone's that means the Chiefs
at little options here's the option
Patrick mahomes Jimmy Garoppolo Travis
Kelce rahim most der there's your four
choices so okay so I'm gonna give you a
fence thing if if the Chiefs win it's
gonna be my home's because they're gonna
swing it he's gonna have three four
hundred yards passing right if the
Niners win they're gonna run the ball
like crazy like they do jimmy geq won't
have his many passing yards or the
statistics he needs to be MVP probably
be most hurt right about that guys never
started a game in his life Steve if
Raheem most dirt becomes the MVP of
Super Bowl 50 for me it would be up
there with Curt's story yeah exactly it
would truly be up there with all some of
the all-time great magic carpet rides
never never know always try your hardest
never give up
type sports stories it would be
unbelievable I love this story always
got to do is just have even half the
game that he had in the NFC Championship
game in a victory for the 49ers yeah
that said Steve pick one yes if I pick
one today I have the right to change it
we're not honestly honestly Steve by the
time Sunday hits nobody cared what
everyone I would say no but I wouldn't
say nobody cares I'd say that I won't
remind them of it you know but go for it
okay so I'm gonna take one team today
and one team a different team Sunday I
don't know I'm not doing I'm not caving
in to your badgering it's faster the
witness let's just say that every single
muscle in your body gives way because
you've just moved around in the wrong
way and can't answer the bell for the
seventh and final hour
game day morning you know what at least
now you'll give your answer it I'm
leaning one way right now in which was
not decision time but I'm leaning when I
hear the phrase defense where's champion
twins championship yes and I look at
those animals that the that the 49ers
have on defense the defensive front
yes that's as good a front as we've seen
in this league in a long long time yes
and so and they've played against mobile
quarterbacks before this year right yes
Russell Wilson a cup tie and Rogers a
couple times Kyle Lowry gave him a
little bit of fits though yeah in Lamar
Jackson I'm gonna need a good job
against all of these guys right so
they're pretty well equipped to contain
Patrick mahomes better than most so I'm
leaning that way but that's as far as
I'm going
okay now that front four you know I'm
trying to give them a nickname it's a
front five they got five first round the
front five the front five I'm giving a
lot of Jackson five I'm trying to give
him the nickname well because as you
know I'm still trying I'm still in there
giving out nickname but yes I will never
get me as waivers never be deterred that
well the gold crush the gold crush it's
not bad is it it's better than the
petrol the patch remains gonna win the
MVP this year so you're picking the
chief I am picking the Chiefs and the
Pat role because old crush the mandrill
that might work huh the gold crush what
do you think let's go with that right
now told it to Dee Ford not that into
Forrest Buckner and they both are
letting it sort of like a foam roll
around little then letting it you know
sit there and see we can go with that
all right that's probably your best one
that's even better than the natural the
natural is still fantastic I don't know
who loves it more when I swing and a
Miss I'm trying to name you two guys or
this guy emoji and turn likes it too
Curt loves it too for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app